MEASURES.
I WILL CHECK IN WITH ONE OF
THEM, CNN'S DAVID CULVER.
>>> BUT FIRST, HERE IS MY TAKE.
UKRAINE'S BRAVE AND BRILLIANT
RESPONSE TO RUSSIA'S ATTACK IS
RIGHTLY BEING CELEBRATED ACROSS
THE WORLD.
BUT IT MIGHT BE OBSCURING A
GROWING DANGER.
WHILE THE ASSAULT ON KYIV AND
THE SURROUNDER REGION HAS
FAILED, MOSCOW'S STRATEGY IN THE
SOUTH AND EAST OF UKRAINE COULD
WELL SUCCEED.
IF IT DOES, RUSSIA WILL HAVE
TURNED UKRAINE INTO AN
ECONOMICALLY CRIPPLED RUMP
STATE, LANDLOCKED AND THREATENED
ON THREE SIDES BY RUSSIAN
MILITARY POWER, ALWAYS
VULNERABLE TO ANOTHER INCURSION
FROM MOSCOW.
IT WILL TAKE MUCH MORE MILITARY
ASSISTANCE FROM THE WEST TO
ENSURE THAT THIS CATASTROPHIC
OUTCOME DOES NOT COME TO PASS.
AS A MILITARY SCHOLAR AND
STRATEGIST POINTED OUT IN THE
FIRST FEW WEEKS OF THE WAR IN AN
ESSAY FOR THE HUDSON INSTITUTE,
THERE ARE TWO DISTINCT WARS
TAKING PLACE IN UKRAINE, ONE IN
THE NORTH AND ONE IN THE SOUTH
AND THE LATTER HAS BEEN
RADICALLY MORE SUCCESSFUL FOR
MOSCOW THAN THE ONE IN THE
NORTH.
RUSSIA HAS BEEN ABLE TO MOVE
FORCES AND SUPPLIES OUT OF ITS
BASES IN CRIMEA AND CAPTURE THE
CITIES OF MELITOPOL AND KHERSON
WHILE SURROUNDING THE CITY OF
MARIUPOL.
THE LATTER IS ENCIRCLED AND
INVADED BY RUSSIAN TROOPS AND
UKRAINIAN FORCES TRAPPED IN
THERE CANNOT BE RESUPPLIED.
UKRAINE'S ACCESS TO THE SEA OF
AZOV HAS BEEN BLOCKED AND AS
POINTED OUT RUSSIAN FORCES HAVE
A CON TIN UG LAND CORRIDOR FROM
CRIMEA DEEP INTO DONBAS.
THEY ARE TRYING TO MOVE WEST
FROM KHERSON TO ODESA.
ODESA IS THE PRIZE AS THE MAIN
PORT FROM WHICH UKRAINE TRADES
WITH THE WORLD, IT IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT CITY FOR UKRAINE
ECONOMICALLY.
IT'S ALSO A CITY REPLETE WITH
SYMBOLIC SIGNIFICANCE.
IT WAS HERE IN 1905 THAT A
MUTINY ON THE BATTLESHIP MADE
FAMOUS BY AT MOVIE MARKED THE
BEGINNING OF THE TROUBLES OF
CZARIST RUSSIA.
WERE ODESA TO FALL UKRAINE WOULD
BE PRACTICALLY LANDLOCKED AND
THE BLACK SEA WOULD ESSENTIALLY
BECOME A RUSSIAN LAKE, WHICH
WOULD ALMOST CERTAINLY TEMPT
MOSCOW TO THEN EXTEND ITS
MILITARY POWER INTO MOLDOVA,
WHICH HAS ITS OWN BREAK-AWAY
REGION FILLED WITH MANY RUSSIAN
SPEAKERS.
PUTIN COULD PRESENT THIS OUTCOME
AS A GRAND VICTORY, LIBERATING
RUSSIAN SPEAKERS, GAINING
CRUCIAL CITIES AND PORTS AND
TURNING UKRAINE INTO A NONVIABLE
VASSLE STATE.
THIS MUST NOT HAPPEN AND THE
UKRAINIANS ARE FIGHTING
FEROCIOUSLY TO PREVENT IT.
IN UKRAINE'S EAST THE RUSSIANS
ARE TRYING TO ADVANCE FROM
KHERSON THROUGH THE CITY OF
MYKOLALV BUT THEY ARE BEING
STYMIED BY THE EXTRAORDINARY
COURAGE OF THE CITY'S
INHABITANTS WHO HAVE REPORTEDLY
BLOWN UP THE BRIDGE THAT
CONNECTS THE CITY TO ODESA AND
BLOCKED THE RAILWAY TRACKS.
THIS WEEK UKRAINIAN FORCES WERE
ABLE TO DEPLOY THEN NEVER BEFORE
USED NEPTUNE MISSILES AND SINK
THE RUSSIAN MISSILE CRUISER
MOSKVA.
STILL IT'S IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER
THAT BEFORE THE INVASION RUSSIA
THIS A 10 TO 1 ADVANTAGE IN
DEFENSE SPENDING OVER UKRAINE
AND PUTIN SEEMS DETERMINED TO
PRESS ON NO MATTER THE COSTS.
SO WHAT CAN THE UNITED STATES
AND THE WEST DO?
MUCH MORE OF EVERYTHING THEY ARE
ALREADY DOING.
UKRAINE NEEDS MORE ARMS,
ESPECIALLY THOSE THAT GIVE IT
MASSIVE A SYMMETRICAL FIGHTING
POWER.
GENERAL MARK HERTLING WHO HAS
BEEN FAR SIDED IN DIAGNOSING
RUSSIA'S WEAKNESSES AND
UKRAINE'S STRENGTHS EXPLAINED TO
ME THAT UKRAINE NEEDS MORE
EQUIPMENT THAT ALLOWS IT TO
MANEUVER QUICKLY AROUND RUSSIA'S
RIGID FORCES.
THAT MEANS HELICOPTERS, ARMED
HUMVEES, MULTIPLE LAUNCH ROCKET
SYSTEMS, DRONES OF EVERY KIND.
TURKISH DRONES HAVE PROVED TO BE
AN EFFECTIVE WEAPON IN THIS
CONFLICT.
HE URGES THAT THEY BE GIVEN
THOSE AS WELL AS KAMIKAZE AND
INTELLIGENCE DRONES.
THE RUSSIAN NAVY WHICH HAS BEEN
MASSING IN THE BLACK SEA
CONTINUES TO POSE A GREAT DANGER
TO ODESA, THREATENING TO EITHER
LAY SIEGE TO IT OR LAUNCH AN
AMPHIBIOUS LANDING BEHIND
UKRAINIAN LINES.
DESPITE THE SUCCESS OF THE
NEPTUNE MISSILE, UKRAINE DOES
NOT HAVE THE CAPACITY TO STOP
THE RUSSIAN NAVY.
NATO SHOULD CONSIDER DOING
SOMETHING SIMILAR TO WHAT IT DID
DURING THE BALKAN WARS OF THE
1990s, IT SHOULD ENFORCE AN
EMBARGO AROUND THOSE WATERS,
PREVENTING RUSSIAN TROOPS FROM
ENTERING TO ATTACK UKRAINE'S
CITIES OR RESUPPLYING RUSSIAN
FORCES.
NATO SHIPS WOULD OPERATE FROM
INTERNATIONAL WATERS, ISSUING
ANY APPROACHING SHIPS NOTICE TO
MARINERS THAT NATO FORCES ARE
ACTIVE IN THE AREA AND WARNINGS
NOT TO ENTER.
ADMIRAL JAMES STAVRIDIS FORMER
SUPREME ALLIED COMMANDER OF NATO
SUPPORTS THE ACTIONS THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS TAKEN, BUT
URGES A MORE AGGRESSIVE RESPONSE
FROM THE WEST ON ALL FRONTS.
GIVE UKRAINE FIGHTER PLANES AND
AIR DEFENSE SYSTEMS, HE TWEETED,
HELP IT WITH CYBER ATTACKS AND
GIVE IT ANTI-SHIP MISSILES TO
SINK RUSSIAN SHIPS IN THE BLACK
SEA.
THE UNITED STATES HAS
APPROPRIATED ABOUT $16 BILLION
IN AID TO UKRAINE.
MEANWHILE, THE WORLD IS EXPECTED
TO PAY ABOUT$320 BILLION TO
RUSSIA THIS YEAR FOR ITS ENERGY.
ECONOMIC SANCTIONS WILL NOT
FORCE PUTIN TO END THE WAR AS
LONG AS THIS GAPING LOOPHOLE
EXISTS.
THE ONLY PRESSURE THAT WILL
FORCE PUTIN TO THE NEGOTIATING
TABLE IS MILITARY DEFEAT IN THE
SOUTH.
PUTIN'S PLAN A FAILED, BUT WE
CANNOT LET HIS PLAN B SUCCEED.
GO TO CNN.COM/FAREED FOR A LINK
TO MY "WASHINGTON POST" COLUMN
THIS WEEK.
>>> AND LET'S GET STARTED.
♪♪ AND LET'S GET STARTED.
♪♪AND LET'S GET STARTED.
♪♪
>>> LET'S GET THE LATEST STATE
OF PLAY IN MARIUPOL AND THE REST
OF THE WORLD FROM CNN'S MATT
RIVERS WHO JOINS US NOW FROM
LVIV.
MATT, WHAT ARE YOU HEARING ABOUT
MARIUPOL WHERE THE RUSSIAN
FORCES ARE MOVING IN?
>> Reporter: FAREED, SO AS OF
ABOUT FOUR HOURS AGO A DEADLINE
THAT AN -- FOR AN ULTIMATUM THAT
WAS GIVEN BY THE RUSSIANS FOR
ALL REMAINING UKRAINIAN
RESISTANCE FIGHTERS IN THE CITY
OF MARIUPOL TO LAY DOWN THEIR
ARMS AND SURRENDER HAS PASSED.
THAT WAS ABOUT FOUR HOURS AGO
AND THE UKRAINIANS SAID THEY
WOULD NOT BE RESPECTING THAT
ULTIMATUM.
THEY SAID THAT THEY WOULD BE
IGNORING IT INSTEAD AND
CONTINUING THE DEFENSE OF THEIR
CITY.
THE RUSSIANS HAVE SINCE
ACKNOWLEDGED THAT THE UKRAINIANS
HAVE IGNORED THAT ULTIMATUM AND
SAID THAT THEY VOWED TO, QUOTE,
ELIMINATE ANY UKRAINIAN
RESISTANCE THAT REMAINS IN THE
CITY SHOULD THEY DECIDE TO KEEP
ON FIGHTING.
AND WHAT ALL OF THAT MEANS,
FAREED, IS THAT THE SIEGE OF THE
CITY OF MARIUPOL WHICH HAS GONE
ON FOR WEEKS NOW TO DEVASTATING
EFFECT IN THAT CITY, NOT ONLY
FOR THE UKRAINIAN FIGHTERS IN
THAT SITUATION, BUT ALSO FOR THE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
CIVILIANS THAT LIVE IN THAT CITY
WILL LIKELY CONTINUE AT THIS
POINT AND, FAREED, I SHOULD NOTE
THERE ARE ABOUT 100,000 CITIZENS
THAT UKRAINE SAYS STILL NEED TO
BE EVACUATED FROM MARIUPOL, NOT
ONE EVACUATION CORRIDOR WAS
AGREED TO BETWEEN THE RUSSIANS
AND THE UKRAINIANS, WHICH MEANS
THROUGHOUT THE DAY ON SUNDAY ALL
OF THOSE TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE REMAIN TRAPPED AND THEY
CAN'T LEAVE.
>> MATT, THE PICTURES WE'VE SEEN
ARE DEVASTATING AND IT FEELS
LIKE THE CIVILIANS CASUALTIES
ARE PROBABLY A LOT HIGHER THAN
PEOPLE REALIZE.
POSSIBLY IN THE TENS OF
THOUSANDS.
WHAT ARE YOU HEARING, VERY
QUICKLY, ABOUT RESUPPLY?
ARE THERE ARMS GETTING THROUGH
TO THE UKRAINIANS?
>> Reporter: NO.
THE SIMPLE ANSWER IS NO.
WE'VE HEARD A LITTLE BIT HERE
AND THERE ABOUT MAYBE SOME ARMS
BEING ABLE TO TRICKLE IN, BUT
WHAT WE'VE HEARD FROM THE
DEFENDERS THAT REMAIN IN THAT
CITY IS THAT THEY HAVE NOT ONLY
GOTTEN NEW AMMUNITION BUT FRESH
FOOD, FRESH WATER, THE THINGS
THAT THEY WOULD NE